on était dans une cellule il y avait si
on avait de la lumière on avait juste et
la lumière qui arrivait en dessous de la
porte mais il n'y avait pas de fenêtre
dans cette cellule et on n'avait pas
beaucoup à manger
donc on avait faim un moment donné je
pense c'était peut-être l'après midi la
porte tout est ouverte
il y avait deux gars avec les visages
masqués et puis les grenades des fusils
comme sa kalachnikov il était armé a
faim et il nous en dit un syrien a dit
sont des enquêteurs eux
il entend résoudre vos problèmes il faut
leur parler correctement vient mais on
peut pas voir ces visages et puis moi je
comme les qualités que gens que je
repérais c'était leur accent je pensais
tout de suite qu'il y avait un accent
anglophone qu'indien un autre accent
francophone gardien c'est tout ce que je
peux dire sur je pensais souvent je leur
ai remerciés je leur ai dit je suis
rocklyn et reconnaissance et la première
fois depuis cinq mois que quelqu'un me
parle comme un être humain et j'étais
gentil et j'aurais dit j'ai faim ils
m'ont donné à manger
jeudi une matraque sans raison pour rien
110 ils n'ont pas à faire ça c'est pas
comme un kick face à ace qui le sait
jamais car a dit allez y vous avez ils
ont dit qu'il avait tué quelqu'un
non666 en fait ils m'ont dit on a tué
plein de gars de la cia mais je faisais
pas confiance mais ils m'ont dit oui on
a tué on a dû tuer beaucoup d'agents
comme toi vous les croyez quoi j'ai
pensé que qui mentait j'avais aussi
l'impression qu'ils étaient près de me
tuer 6es avait eu l'ordre s'ils avaient
si le chef d'al qaïda ou n'importe qui
d'y aller tué sept américains il
l'aurait fait donc deux secondes
ils se sont soumis à une psychologie
islamique qui est dangereuse qui te
permet de connaître des crimes contre
dans ton frère humain et peut-être qu'il
pourrait il pourra nous parler de sa
caisse qui qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé
là bas quand vous étiez en syrie est ce
que vous regrettez ce que vous avez fait
moi je suis prêt à pardonner défendre
est qu au moins ils disent on a commis
des crimes là bas est ce que voudrait
qu'ils soient arrêtés ces jeunes là les
canadiens que vous avez rencontré vente
seulement c'est pas j'aimerais qu'ils je
pense qu'ils doivent faire face au
système judiciaire dans ce que parce
qu'il faudrait que nous en tant que
société que nous on dise en stacked on
respecte certains valeurs et qu' ils ont
quand contre arts et les valeurs qui
sont au fond de notre société ça c'est
que quand tu vois une personne une
personne vulnérable qui a besoin d aide
il faut l'aider faut faire quelque chose
il faut pas essayer de lui voler